meghan markle had a pretty good day in
court
on tuesday a uk judge ruled that her
legal fees after a recent court victory
should be paid for how much 1.87
million dollars is she'd been through a
high court case against the mail on
sunday and just a few days
before the pregnancy announcement she
won that privacy court case so a big
victory
for megan the court ruling follows
megan's successful lawsuit against
associated newspapers
the parent company of a british tabloid
that published a private letter she sent
her father
thomas markle last month a high court
judge in london
ruled the publisher invaded megan's
privacy the news org stated they have
plans to appeal the ruling
were you silent or were you silenced
i just want to make it clear to
everybody there
is no subject that's off limit meanwhile
the world is anxiously awaiting
megan and her husband prince harry's
first sit-down interview since their
royal exit
it's been unbelievably tough for the two
of us but at least we had each other
in this preview clip harry references
his mother princess diana
and her tragic death after she was
chased by paparazzi
my biggest concern was history repeating
itself you know for me
i'm just really relieved and happy to be
sitting here
talking to you with my wife by my side
because i can't begin to imagine what it
must have been like for her
going through this process by herself
all those years ago
oprah with megan and harry a cbs
primetime special will air on march 7th
it's airing amid the alleged friction
between harry and his family
post-royal separation the couple really
want this to be an interview
in which they can sit down and tell
their side of the story up until now
we've heard versions of their story
through the voices and the retelling of
other people this is their first
opportunity to sit down and talk about
the past year
in their own words and get this harry
and megan's sit down with oprah is
scheduled to air just hours after the
royal family will be featured
in the bbc broadcast a celebration for
commonwealth day
according to my palace sources the bbc
picked
the date of the 7th of march this was
decided
weeks and weeks ago i think well in
advance
of the oprah airing date there is a
feeling that while the sussexes have the
last word over them being stripped of
their royal titles
the queen is going to have the first
word when it comes to their broadcast
[Music]
special